today on the anime zone a review of K on
a show following the story of a group of
girls as a former band and struggle
towards their dream of playing the music
they love da occasional da da boy but
the summative scheme yeah hey where the
[ __ ] is the music
Klaus what the [ __ ] are you doing here
this is my show um well you see how did
you even get in my house
look I just figured that your show is
pretty popular so I thought I might just
so you flew to England go home and stop
sniffing my laundry but my flight
doesn't leave until tomorrow fine you
can stay but you do know that k-on is a
mo a show right oh [ __ ] the Moyes honor
is something I've always had an actual
fear for when it comes to anime there's
just something about cute girls who look
about 12 doing cute things of issac
cover half their [ __ ] face that make
me want to leg it a mob for inevitably
here the exasperated a sound that is
apparently the only response a group of
cute girls can make to just about every
sentence ever ah have a problem with
cute girls not a big fan of girls giggle
Klaus don't you start or so help me
sorry continue and so we have k on an
anime seemingly sprung about cuz Kyoto
Animation apparently saw a popular that
one concert episode in Hara he was and
decided to base a whole anime around the
episode our story starts off with Yui
who the main [ __ ] character who a
ditzy airheaded girl who has just
started high school but has no idea what
club to join and after a bit of [ __ ]
around
she decides to finally join it's a like
music club come on there's more to it
than that
really really let's see if you can do
any better than well she joins thinking
she could just get by playing the
castanets but the energetic reet su and
her comic foil meal convinced her to be
their lead guitarist even though she
can't play the guitar but she she
decides she can learn and [ __ ] I don't
know oh this is hard
Christ give me the mic so the three of
them are joined by a quite rich girl who
can play the keyboards and they drink
tea and
and eat cakes oh yeah and
[ __ ] it nothing nothing happens in this
anime so apparently Moe way is Japanese
for faffing about there is no grand
overarching plot no incredible drama
just girls being silly in eating cake
don't get me wrong I don't think every
anime needs to be Paradise Lost but
everything in this anime is just so
insubstantial the characters don't even
face any real problems
oh no the guitarist doesn't have a
guitar let's spend an entire episode of
everyone working together a part-time
job to help her earn some money which
Indiana's rendered pointless anyway
because rich goes dad he apparently owns
the [ __ ] music shop and practically
buys her the guitar let's all go to
summer camp to practice then not
practice but then it doesn't matter
because I guess we didn't need to
because why should a band ever have to
practice really the point we're trying
to get at this story isn't so much a
story as it is just following four girls
acting like well girls and the plot
itself really just serves to throw these
characters into different situations
the girls consist of usual rails
stereotypes and tropes that we found
scattered throughout the slice-of-life
merge onre including the shy one the
hyper one the posh one the organized
want young assisted the pedophile bait
and [ __ ]
hold on gig I've got some good names -
there's the thick-headed energetic one
the serious one who's also a fraidy-cat
the quiet one who just happens to be
rich and [ __ ] but hey maybe it's not
about the characters they make up a band
after all so maybe it's all about the
band and there are some music no luck
them afraid as well this show is very
much marketed as a musical anime and the
opening and ending would have you
believe that this is an anime about a
group of girls forming a band with the
intent of rocking their cute little
hearts out on the stage music is very
much not the main focus of this anime
even if there were a few concert
performances to let you get an idea let
me just take you through the average
amount of music they play per episode
that was it
truth be told throughout the course of
13 episodes they managed to play a
combined total of maybe three songs and
two of them are the same damn song I
understand that bands can be expensive
and writing a bunch of different
interesting songs can be hard but if
you're going to make an anime about a
band then maybe just maybe you should
consider playing a few Tunes it wouldn't
have even been so bad if the songs they
ended up playing were well written
catchy rock songs but in the end a
soundtrack consisted of the most generic
uninteresting j-pop runoff that sounds
as boring and redundant as the plot
itself instead the bios used as a device
bring the various different
personalities together because all they
seem to do every episode is eat cake and
drink tea yes and these young ladies may
not be able to play an interesting note
of music to save their lives but if
there's one thing they know how to do
its eat cake and drink tea in fact I can
say with some certainty that they spend
more time drinking tea than they do
playing music no but their fullness of
confectionaries goes way beyond
obsession because no matter what problem
arises they seem to solve everything by
eating cake and drinking some
[ __ ] tea someone feeling a
little bit depressed
[ __ ] tea tensions high between
band members that are fights about to
break out [ __ ] tea the possible
end to the human race as we know due to
natural disasters the end of the Mayan
calendar and fallout from nuclear war
from world war three [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] tea [ __ ] I don't
care if sharing tea and cake is
important to their friendship or even
their culture there are other things
people can do when they want to talk and
the anime seems self-aware of this in
one episode essentially pointing out how
they are always drinking tea you know
what k on that doesn't make it okay I
can point out my herpes but that doesn't
mean the tick of the dark street corner
will want to [ __ ] me well you could
always try the chicken a dark
back-alleys hmm it's not a bad I was
joking speaking of jokes where the hell
is the comedy in the series this anime
wasn't focusing on a plot or the music
like it was advertised then I would
expect to have more of a comedy side to
it but in all honesty while there were
many scenes that were amusing nothing in
a shot she made me laugh out loud for
any given length of time oh I disagree
what about when mio is crouching in the
corner cuz she's afraid oh look there
she goes again yeah haha oh man and
again t [ __ ] he but my guess there
are approximately 10 funny moments per
episode of k own and 8 out of those 10
are reused every damn episode the jokes
are cute and some are even a little
wacky at first but K on has no qualms
when it comes to beating a dead horse
but I have to give credit where credit's
due and there are a few things in this
shows favor firstly the anime looks
gorgeous with a lot of attention being
paid to the instruments they play all
the instruments are real-life models and
there's little things like this as a
fellow guitarist help is sure to stand
out though it's a bit disheartening
knowing that this dance can afford a
better guitar than me plus the animation
especially during the concert scenes are
amazing
with the movements perfectly syncing up
to the music being played nowhere is
this more prevalent than in the opening
and closing songs which are hands down
the best part of the show the music is
surprisingly addictive and the art
stylish especially in the closing song
there's so much attention to detail and
after the first episode it really gives
you hope that the anime will be full of
great stuff like this it isn't but it
should be though that again this is
kyoto animation after all who seemed to
be the expert when it comes to creating
addictive and gimmicky opening and
endings right lucky star in hara he
though i have noticed one reason they
seem to be really well done is because
always done in a way where the animation
could go with basically any music and it
will fit casing points
but it's not like I can't see where the
appeal comes from in a my sense
it definitely Jesus job because it shows
undoubtably cute yes
it's really cute there were times in
this show I even felt like going ah
which points I stopped watching for a
while through my fear that if I was
exposed to this show for too long I
would eventually sprout a vagina
sadly aside from some good credit
sequences and the little attention to
detail that's all it is cute there's
nothing else to really enjoy about this
anime the music what little there is
lacks any genuine appeal which is pretty
disappointing for an anime about a band
what little comedy there is is repeated
until it's become dull or even
irritating the characters aren't even
anything more than cookie-cutter cliches
with little to separate them from the
Horde of high school girls populating
slice-of-life anime overall ko and
certainly wasn't as bad as I thought it
would be but it really is just nothing
but mediocrity that games maybe a few
more points for high production values
it has nothing you to the table and
everything in it has been done before
and better elsewhere if you want a band
anime go watch Beck or Nana if you want
a slice of life the great as among a
diyos I'm better than this and if you
want to calm the heck angel beats I'd be
laughing 10 times harder than anything
in this and that's not even primarily a
comedy make no mistake this is nothing
more than your typical run-of-the-mill
slice of live show that has the added
gimmick of music in it though if you're
looking for something cute to watch more
completely switching off your brain
you'll probably enjoy this and if you do
please slap yourself for making the show
the basis of about 90% of anime coming
out now you mindless mo a zombie you
know Giga this was pretty fun maybe next
time you can swing by the PS o HB
dot-com studio by studio dreaming that
creepy basement of yours perhaps and by
next time Jimmy's sexually assault
perhaps get out
you